denial of evolution is unique to the
United States I mean we are the world's
most advanced technological so I mean
you could say Japan but generally United
States is where most of the innovation
still happens people still move to the
United States and that's largely because
of the intellectual capital we have that
the general understanding of science
when you have a portion of the
population doesn't believe in that it
holds everybody back really evolution is
the fundamental idea in all of life
science in all of biology it's like it's
very much analogous to trying to do
geology without believing in tectonic
plates you're just not going to get the
right answer your whole world is just
going to be a mystery instead of an
exciting place as my old professor Carl
Sagan said when you're in love you want
to tell the world so once in a while I
get people that really that or that
claim they don't believe in evolution
and my response generally is on why not
really why not your world just becomes
fantastically complicated when you don't
believe in evolution I mean here are
these ancient dinosaur bones or fossils
here is a radioactivity here are distant
stars that are just like the our star
but they're a different point in their
lifecycle
the idea of deep time of this billions
of years explains so much of the world
around us if you try to ignore that your
your worldview just becomes crazy it's
just a untenable itself inconsistent and
I say to the grown-ups if you want to
deny evolution and live in your in your
world that's completely inconsistent
with everything we observe in the
universe that's fine but don't make your
kids do it because we need them we need
scientifically literate voters and
taxpayers for the future we need people
that can we need engineers that can
build stuff solve problems these are
just really hard thing
it's really a hard thing you know in
another couple centuries that worldview
I'm sure will be just won't exist I mean
it's it's there's no evidence for it